foreign
how do we stop preaching to the choir
what can we do to grab the attention of
those individuals who are disengaged
I ask these questions as an artist
as an educator
and as a lifelong resident of Miami
Florida one of the most climate
vulnerable cities in the United States
in Miami we're already seeing storm
drains that are up with water after
heavy rainfalls
and cars and properties that are damaged
due to flooding from high tide
and we've all seen the devastation
of hurricane Ian as it barreled at 150
miles an hour
bringing 10 feet of storm surge
to the Gulf Coast just two and a half
hours from my home
my home sits at six feet above sea level
but today
we see cranes populating Miami Skyline
building more and more skyscrapers at
the water's edge
thanks to this Brazen over development
many miamians aren't aware of the threat
that sea level rise poses to their
families
their homes and their communities
I myself wasn't aware of just how dire
Miami situation was until I traveled to
Antarctica
I went there in 2006 as part of the
National Science Foundation Arctic
artist and writers program
I spoke with Scientists there and I
learned just how vulnerable my city was
I was standing on the very ice that
threatened to melt and drown the only
place I've ever called home
so I took that ice and I made art with
it
I took Isa glaciologists brought back
from their field stations and melted it
to create a series of Antarctic Ice
paintings
paintings made in Antarctica with
Antarctica and about Antarctica
but they were just about Antarctica they
were about where Antarctica was going
I returned to Miami transformed by that
experience and pivoted my art practice
to one where for 15 years now I've been
trying to ask
how do we best engage the public
around climate issues
just a few years ago I worked with the
village of Pinecrest to develop a
socially engaged art project that would
make sea level rise impossible to ignore
we called it the underwater homeowners
association
let that sink in for a second
we use those Antarctic Ice paintings as
the backdrop for yard signs that would
map the elevation of people's homes
people use an app to find out how many
feet above sea level their homes were
and then they would either paint that
number on a yard sign or take home a
pre-made one and they would place it in
their front yards now you can imagine
when your neighbor from across the
street asks you what that number eight
in front of your house means
perfect opportunity for you to tell them
that they too live at eight feet above
the sea and it is in their interest in
their personal and financial interest to
understand the consequences of a warming
planet
the strangeness or weirdness of these
signs remember these aren't political
signs these aren't home for sale signs
these are elevation markers
is a key component to socially engaged
project that makes random people stop
long enough to ask what is this about
and it is in that way that many of my
neighbors realize that all they lived
farther Inland from the ocean
they weren't necessarily less vulnerable
to the rising Seas you see in Miami
elevation generally increases as you
move Inland until you hit this Ridge
and then it starts groping as you
approach the Florida Everglades the
River of Grass or what I call Miami's
second coastline
as these yard signs were popping up
house by house block by block I worked
with schools to paint four Street
intersections with their respective
elevations we call that road elevation
Drive
because it showcased the elevation of a
neighborhood
Rising as you drove Inland and then
dropping after you crossed that barely
noticeable Ridge
and as if being flanked by bodies of
water on both sides wasn't enough
Miami has a third Coastline it's the
water beneath our feet
in the aquifer
this is where salt water intrusion is
presently threatening our drinking water
and it is the reason why when it comes
to sea level rise dams are not a
solution for Miami
you see my city is built on porous
Limestone Rock and the water will just
come up through it
now as information about this about our
project started getting out
all hell broke loose
people started calling the mayor's
office what are you doing how are you
supporting a project that's going to
inherently diminish our property values
and the Realtors were aghast how are we
going to make sales in the neighborhood
this backlash this desire to hide a
number that's in every single one of our
flood insurance documents
made the city officials
actually reconsider the support for the
project but by then it was too late the
project had broad Community Support
hundreds of signs were all over the
neighborhood
people wanted to do something
so we convened monthly underwater
homeowners association meetings
where people came together and they
learned from relevant scientists and
experts and practitioners and ultimately
began planning for a future with faulty
septic tanks and
risky real estate
and water that would rise
but unlike a hurricane storm surge will
not recede
I want to emphasize what I'm talking
about here
I'm talking about social practice about
socially engaged art the objects are
important the yard signs the street
murals
but the art is the process
the art lives in the interaction
in the community coming together to plan
to strategize
it is in this way that socially engaged
art provides a mechanism that brings
different people together around a
shared challenge
and importantly
it generates a sense of agency of
responsibility
I first started working with my
neighbors on environmental issues
when I witnessed a destruction of
wetlands on a drive down to the Florida
Keys
miles upon miles of mangroves were being
bulldozed to make space for a wider Road
and I imagined
someone driving down that road in the
future being clueless about the
ecosystem that once thrived there
just like many of us today are oblivious
to the nature we've already destroyed
so I used Eco art I I brought my
neighbors my South Floridians on walks
through Majestic Mangrove forests there
we were knee-deep in water crawling
through Mangrove roots and I would
explain that these trees sequester
carbon from the atmosphere they support
biodiversity they protect us from Storm
surges
we collect that Mangrove propagules
seedlings that we would then give to
store owners on Lincoln Road the busiest
shopping area in Miami Beach
we asked those Stone owners
to grow those mangroves as vertical
nurseries right there inside their
stores
our volunteers put the seedlings in
composable cups and hung them on the
merchant Windows as installations that
referenced the city grid that displaced
the mangroves on that very Barrier
Island
when the
people walk by that store
it's really unexpected to see a bunch of
mangroves in a window
so he has a store owner what is this
about someone says Ah these mangroves
are reclaiming their Island Mangrove
seedlings used to hang on this very
location on trees before all of this
concrete was poured
well when the installations came down
after the ceilings were germinated we
planted them
25 acres of them on Biscayne Bay but
more importantly
we inspired thousands of South
Floridians to become environmental
stewards to care for the environment we
did this in partnership with dozens of
schools museums and libraries and it
wasn't just about creating ecosystems
above and below the water line
it was about developing a Cadre of eco
emissaries
of creative problem solvers
of miamians driven by empathy and love
of community
art did that art has that power
art has the power to break down barriers
and Bridge divides
art can help us see things in different
ways when you look at one of those yard
signs with a number on it
and ask what is this about that's the
moment
when the seed of awareness is planted in
you we've piqued your curiosity
when you're engaged in an eco-art
project and begin caring for mangroves
walking in that Forest collecting them
sharing talking about them installing
them and then planting them
you begin to develop a personal
connection with nature
finding ways to provoke that moment of
inquiry
and importantly
creating Pathways for further action
that's what socially engaged art does
and it is my hope that all of us across
all sectors
use the power of Art
that universal language the power of Art
to engage our communities
so that individuals can tap into their
own creativity
and work with others in finding
Innovative approaches
to build a more just a more loving and a
more beautiful world
thank you
[Applause]